Education reformers love education
technology. This has been true for a long
time. The radio, the TV, the desktop computer:
each was going to revolutionize
schooling. Guess what: They didn't.
Technology is a powerful tool, and like
any tool what matters is how we use it.
We have to use it right and that means
understanding why it matters. Technology
is great at offering access. For kids in
rural schools, who don't have access to
advanced placement classes, online
delivery of courses can make all the
difference. Technology is great at
supporting personalization. For teachers
with 25 kids, it can be hard to tend to
the needs of each and every one.
Computerized assessments can make a huge
difference. But iPads aren't going to
eliminate the need for teachers. Kids
need role models, mentors, and a kick in
the pants. Technology can't do any of
that. But technology can make a huge
difference. It can help teachers do their
job better, and it can support kids as
they learn. And honestly, that's more than enough.
To learn more about my take on
education technology, check the links in
the description below. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like a AEI
scholars to cover in 60 seconds.